après l'amérique l'europe adoptent la
vaccination contre la poliomyélite en
france et la petite commune savoyarde de
belles entre ken les honneurs de la
première vaccination massive
tous les enfants et les jeunes gens soit
presque la moitié de la population du
village ont reçu une dose de vaccin mis
au point par l'institut pasteur
[Musique]
en allemagne de l'ouest une vaccination
semblable a eu lieu parmi les moins de 4
ans si les parents étaient tous
volontaires
les jeunes sujets ont diversement
apprécié l'opération
[Musique]
de la réprobation caractérisée à la
différence la plus évidente
toute une gamme d'opinion a été exprimée
[Musique]
défiant nous cependant des apparences ne
confondons pas courage avec insouciance
d'un autre côté disons nous bien qu'il y
aura toujours des gens fermés au progrès
[Musique]